if you told me that it makes him
personally
30 million dollars spread evenly over
the next 10 years i wouldn't be
surprised
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back all right what up
uh sean here we got sam and then we got
special guest dan
held the dan held from the bitcoin space
and on twitter you've probably seen him
around
i told my brother-in-law um that you
were on the podium he was very excited
i've told him about every guest so far
and you got one of the biggest reactions
he was a
i think he's a paid subscriber to your
newsletter or something like that so
he's
he's very into you and on the other hand
i think sam has no [__] clue who you
are so i think it's the perfect mix
i know some stuff about you sam knows
nothing about you
and i think it'll be fun i only know
that
sean says that you're cool and you're in
bitcoin i know nothing about you
um we got an hour to figure it out
whenever one of us proposes a guest it's
like you put that guest
it's like you have to go take the stand
and have an oath that this person's
gonna be good and then you better be
able to
lawyer up and defend why this person's a
guest and so he'll every time any time
he mentions the name to me i'm like why
the [__] are we having that person on
and then he'll like defend it and then
same here i was like no no this is gonna
be
gonna be interesting because couple i
think a couple reasons we should talk
about crypto
and then we should talk about i think
like kind of like building your personal
brand because you've done a really good
job of that
and so we'll we'll do both of those
during this during this convo
but i want to start with like give
people the like what's the one minute
story of who the heck you are and yeah
yeah and i don't know like
give us the one-minute story of dan held
yeah the elevator pitch
yeah so i from texas originally i grew
up in dallas 25 years in dallas
i studied finance and undergrad stumbled
and bumbled my way into tech
i didn't know what i was doing when i
first built my my first software product
in the space
it was successful from there learned how
to formalize some of my skills around
product management and marketing
um worked at a couple different early
stage crypto companies so i was at some
of the first
crypto companies i worked at like
blockchain.com
i've had two exits in the crypto space
so i've sold two of my products
and then i've also worked at uber where
i was on writer growth led by andrew
chen so one of his directs
and the growth marketing team so i've
had big company
classic uh tech experience but also a
lot of kind of that startup hustle
and early stage crypto which early stage
crypto is kind of wild west
um yeah which i guess fits my my texas
attitude so
and so tell people the source you got
into crypto
bitcoin uh bitcoin specifically you're a
bitcoin guy i should i shouldn't keep
saying crypto too much
um bitcoin back in i think 2012 or so
bitcoin was maybe 10 bucks back then um
what you know what caught your interest
how did you hear about it what's the
origin story for you
yeah so i got back in 2012 uh my buddy
paid me back for a beer with something
called a cassatious coin
a cassatious coin are those gold coins
that you see in all those news articles
where they talk about bitcoin
they were physical bitcoins essentially
and that was a good time
and in that 2012 era bitcoin is so new
and weird and different that that was
like a good bridge from the physical
fiat paper money world to the to the
digital bitcoin world
uh from there my background is in
finance i really dug the 21 million hard
cap as a solution to bad central banking
policies
i i mean i was in undergrad during the
2008 financial crisis studying finance
and i'm like
my professors don't know [__] right
either to the people on tv and
neither do these books that i'm reading
and that's what kind of kind of shook my
foundational
uh trust and belief in the existing
financial system and that's when bitcoin
came around when i saw that i was like
this is a good
new way to be rebuild the financial
system without having to trust these
institutions
and sam i don't know if you know this
sam do you know when uh satoshi
signed the first block he put a he put a
message in there do you know do you have
you ever heard what this
is no but i i love that guy's stories i
mean
the the myth or if it's real i don't
know what the truth is but i love the
story behind it
and dan i don't know if you know it off
top of your head but but do you know
what it is
yeah so satoshi was a really crazy
character in terms of his expertise i
mean he understood like human game
he understood game theory encryption all
sorts of different other topics and wove
this all together to build bitcoin
bitcoin isn't just software
it it wraps itself around understanding
human lovers to press
like greed of how the price cycles as
the price goes up
people become more aware of it and by an
expectation of the price going higher
um so satoshi you know really understood
humans intimately and part of this that
he wove into the first block was the
genesis block message
and it said uk chancellor on the verge
of second bailout for banks
so that was the only message that
satoshi ever put into the bitcoin
blockchain
and so it's a very clear signal that
bitcoin wasn't here to disrupt a visa or
paypal
bitcoin is here to disrupt the existing
financial system in central banking
right and so there's like a the mission
the mission was sort of like i don't
know cleverly baked in which i just
i just love i'm like you sam where i'm
like the more i learn
about the origins the more this [__]
seems like it's out of a movie uh it
doesn't seem like
real life it's like oh this anonymous
creator is like how's anything anonymous
nowadays right like
there's there's like way you know like
the way they caught the silk road guy
was like his
the way he was typing or whatever
matched some review he left on a movie
message board or so you know there's
always something
like that there's always a breadcrumb
trail actually is it still anonymous
i mean obviously no one's come out could
it been the the the guy who had als and
died i mean what what's what do you
what do smart people who know what's
dancing what's dan's theory
uh the uh everyone's got their own
favorite satoshi tale
all right so one is hell fenny the one
that you just described he had
als and died i think in 2012 or 2013.
uh hal finney is a classic favorite
because he ghost wrote pgp
encryption and bitcoin's proof of work
system is based on his early reusable
proof-of-work system that he created
earlier
bitcoin wasn't a new innovation it just
kind of frankenstein all these other
innovations together and that's how
satoshi built bitcoin
hal finney has the demeanor of bitcoin
he was also the first recipient of a
bitcoin transaction or
he was sending it to himself right which
is what by the way if you ever work with
developers that's what they do
when they're testing [__] out the first
thing they do is they send it to my
account a to my account to sean
sean but the ghost writing pgp
encryption back in that era with phil
zimmerman
pgp encryption was considered a weapon
by the defense
uh by by the department of defense so
when he goes through pgp he knew that he
was potentially going to be convicted
for like illegal
uh arms trafficking wow so he understood
what it meant to take on a government at
this scale
and so he and when he when i say ghost
wrote
he goes toward it because his name isn't
officially on it so same with bitcoin he
was one of the few people to
that would have built bitcoin in that
fashion uh you know hiding behind a
pseudonym
of satoshi and using that because that
was critical that the project had no
face to it
had no central weak point because if you
could find satoshi and he's sort of a
weak point
in the governance structure and in the
ownership structure that could undermine
the the the long-term success of the
protocol
so yeah hal is a classic favorite died
around the same time that
satoshi stopped doing anything we
haven't seen a mess
a flare from satoshi's sense right
that's right satoshi hasn't signed a
message with his private key which would
concretely determine that that is
satoshi or give us a strong
determination that that is satoshi
so so that timeline makes sense that's
theory one what's the two
32 is the nsa so 32 is that it's the nsa
because the nsa builds weapons and
bitcoin is a financial weapon it could
destabilize countries and destabilize
their currencies
and so this is just a more fun i mean
totally off the wall sort of thinking
but
so let's say a group of cryptographers
which some of the best in the world work
at the nsa
come up with bitcoin because they're
tasked with building a weapon and after
they build it they go wait a second
maybe we should just release this into
the wild because we do believe that this
is good for humankind
right and they release it as kind of
like it's like a frankenstein experiment
let out of the lab
uh so i think that one's kind of fun i
mean there's no there's no facts behind
that
where would you put your lab leak
hypothesis for for the pandemic
basically that's that's what you're
saying i think one's more realistic than
the other maybe
what uh would you bet your money on one
of those dan
probably more of the health anyone i
feel that it's an individual
so that's always a question too is it an
individual or a group of people
i cube more individual designed by
committee is really hard to do with
something as
niche and like incredible like an
incredible breakthrough like bitcoin
right so i think that one person just
had that genius to take all these
elements and put them together to create
bitcoin
versus a group of developers trying to
figure out how to build this thing
and and there's also the other thing
which is like it's just somebody else so
if you were gonna
apply your percentages what percent is
half any nsa or
other uh this is super tough but maybe
like 50 hellfini uh 30
nixabo and 20 nsa
[Laughter]
all right i like that um okay so you
discover bitcoin because some guy gives
you a coin
uh and you don't you're not just like
dude what is this like can i have my 10
bucks please and
and so you go you read about it uh what
happens that night so you go and you
what you read the white paper you join
the forums you just start reading about
it online
and then like i guess like take us
through the thought process of you going
from where you were then
to like where you are now where bitcoin
is like
you know a pretty major part of your
life yeah and i can kind of weave in my
early entrepreneurship like in tech
part of that too because it's all kind
of intertwined together so
i start to read about it the 21 million
hardcap the monetary policy i see this
as a huge breakthrough because if you
remove the subjectivity of
choosing what an appropriate rate of
inflation is you've solved the problem
of monetary theory so like
satoshi solved the problem of like going
hey we shouldn't constantly figure out
what the rate of inflation should be
we should fix it and the economy can
reorient around that genius breakthrough
so that got me really hooked um i worked
at a small investment firm in dallas
nothing anyone would know it's a really
tiny one wasn't prestigious or anything
like that
they relocated me to san francisco to
open up their west coast portfolio
out in san francisco i during the uh
it was the april bitcoin run up from 10
to 260
back down to 100. i was going to the
bitcoin meetups in san francisco
this is where like brian and fred from
coinbase were hanging out and same with
jared kenneth from trade hill and
jesse powell from kraken mike the
company now
i mean there's only what were those like
because we were just in miami
uh when the bitcoin conference was
happening and it was kind of like a
like a bunch of fools act in the fool i
thought i didn't attend but just through
what you what was coming out on social
media i guess
and everything every community changes
from like when it's the outsiders
and um you know just the true believers
to like
you know 10 years later 11 years later
what what it looks like is is very very
different every community changes all of
my friend my roommate was
buying i was mining in 11 and 12. and
they were just hardcore devs and nerds
so what were those like so i remember i
was still working at a small investment
firm so i'm rolling up in [__]
business casual
to a developer intuitive bitcoin
there's only a dozen of us i mean it was
tiny and actually i put pictures on
twitter where you can see pictures from
the old meetup i mean
it's just a it's a cooler of pbrs and a
bunch of people kind of geeking out on
this thing called bitcoin
right march april 2013 hit price goes to
260.
boom you've got like vcs slanging out
business cards everyone's excited
there's 150 people that come to the
meetup
you know there's this energy this
palpable energy and then the may 2013
conference happens
the winklevi announced they've been
they've been they've bought bitcoin
they're involved the the conference had
like a few hundred people which was kind
of wild
if you see coinbase's booth from videos
from back then they printed out like an
eight and a half by eleven that just had
coinbase on it like they just printed it
off their computer in the office or
their
printer in the office and taped it on
their booth and brian and fred were the
guys manning the booth
so like that's how early it was super
super early in the space
and during that moment that's when i
found a problem
a problem that needed to be solved which
was finding the real-time price of
bitcoin on your mobile device
at that time there was no app in the app
store that gave you real-time market
data
which is crazy because bitcoin
fluctuates a lot and people you know
were constantly opening up their phone
to check the price of bitcoin
all the other developers before then
just refresh the price every 15 minutes
or so
so me and a buddy put it together now i
didn't know what i was doing i was a
finance guy
you know trying to figure out how to
make a product and so i just became
really obsessed with solving this
problem
and so i knew enough in photoshop to
where i could design the app so i just
looked at apps that i liked
took elements from that to design
zeroblock which was this product and
designed it and we designed it really
really simply
because i couldn't design anything more
complex back in that day skeuomorphism
was the popular design aesthetic
and we did flat ui because i couldn't
design bevels and stuff
so i just became obsessed with solving
this problem for myself
turns out a lot of other people had that
problem too and that's where it kind of
like stumbled my way into some product
fundamentals of like it's all about
solving a problem for your customer
and then i got into a tinge of growth
marketing
where i found how to hack my way to the
number two spot for the word bitcoin in
the app store
so we got most of our installs you know
how did you do that
what was the hack yeah so apple at the
time when they really
originally built the app store they
forked it from itunes
and so there's an old character limit
that they had for titles of songs which
is 255 characters but they also allowed
that character limit for
app titles it was truncated after 60
words
basically but you can fill it in words
in the top in the core title old school
keyword stuffing yeah i learned
old school growth hacking technique of
just keyword stuffing but it worked
now it was sort of a crapshoot to see if
the app store reviewers would approve it
but
one out of five would and if you did you
could clinch that spot
right so that kind of started my
fascination with both products
and with growth marketing kind of on the
more hacky side of things
and yeah that was my that was my initial
foray into tech and then we sold
serial block at the end of the year to
blockchain.com uh blockchain.com is
still around today it's a really popular
wallet
i was the first product manager there
and so kind of that's what i mean by
stumbled and bumbled my way into tech is
specific yeah i didn't have any formal
background i just kind of
was really empathetic with solving a
problem for my customer wanted to
propagate the the message of my product
and that's how i learned those two
skills all right let's talk about some
ideas sean
shall we yeah so dan i don't know if you
know but this is the ideas podcast where
we basically
say okay that like i'm interested in the
past but to the extent that
i learned cool things and then i'm like
all right let's get to the future what's
the future look like so
so idea so i think there's really like i
guess like let's start in the bitcoin
crypto space what problems do you see
today that you think somebody needs to
solve like back then
there was no real-time price data that
was a problem that needed solving sure
what are you seeing today as a problem
that needs solving
yeah there's one idea that's
particularly fascinating but it's not
very sexy
now there's a lot of really good
intersections there where you find value
and like this new idea because not a lot
of people are looking at it
it's around private wealth management
for crypto holders
imagine a current crypto billionaire
walks into a family office multi-family
office and they're like hey
i'd like you to help manage my portfolio
and they sit down five suits in front of
this guy with a hoodie
and they say hey well uh first of all
we'd like to take
you know a two percent management fee of
all your holdings and they're like well
i
said i self-custody my coin right and
they'd be like i don't even know what
that means
right you know and then they would go
well how much how much of your net worth
is in crypto and they would say
90 and the first thing they would say is
diversify
right the existing uh private wealth
managers and multi-family offices have
no idea of how to service
crypto wealthy crypto folks i mean you
can't even you can i
i told mike at the bank today let's buy
some ethereum and they were like oh
we we can't it's ridiculous
i mean it's absolutely ridiculous it's
it's so antiquated they just don't talk
don't even talk the same language as all
these crypto folks right like
i'm a more bitcoin guy but if you go
down like the ethereum rabbit hole
there's a whole i mean there's so much
complexity
and how those defy and smart contracts
work
it's where you need like a full tax team
to solve that problem too
but these i mean i've been in this space
for almost nine years
i know more billionaires on this planet
than probably anyone else
because of because of crypto because
crypto has
created so many and not institutions but
individuals
who have billions to where
bitcoin is probably bitcoin plus
ethereum has probably created more
individual billionaires than any other
project right exactly i think that's got
to be true which is kind of insane like
more than microsoft more than
amazon more more than any of those
projects how many crypto billionaires do
you know
how many billionaires do you know um i
would say off the top my head at least
at least ten ten how many crypto
how about um a hundred million on up
oh man i mean i would assume i at least
know 100 or so folks that probably have
that much doubt look bitcoin people
don't tell you how much they have
right but you can kind of assume based
on how long they've been in this space
and what companies they worked at and
how much their net worth was back then
and
probably yeah i mean it's a general
assumption but how much of your personal
money were you putting into this before
your bitcoin started
like making sense like were you putting
like a hundred grand into this in 2012
when it was like who the [__] knows if
this is gonna work because 100 grand to
you at you're
like i wish well you could do it i wish
you were really young
that would have been a lot of money yeah
i didn't have that much money man i mean
look i was like uh
25 26 just out of co and i was in i you
know my first job was in dallas i was
making 45k a year it wasn't like a ton
of money
yeah and then i got into tech eventually
and of course that went up quite a bit
but that was in 2013 2014. now um
my average cost basis was 10 to 100 but
there's a bunch of coins i got from
in the hundreds to thousands right so
i think a lot of people look at like
crypto ogs like myself and they assume
we had like a million dollars sitting
around that we all dumped in at five
dollars a bitcoin
and also i wasn't a perfect toddler i
day traded i traded litecoin i
traded a bunch of other stuff just for
fun i even mined primecoin
so i'm not you know on my bitcoin
journey i've touched a bunch of other
coins as well
um so no one's a perfect toddler
psychologically
are you able to buy the dip when the dip
is like 30 000 and it's like well my
cost basis is
192 and uh you know or like whatever
it's five
even even if it's three thousand even my
cost basis is three thousand buying at
thirty
so buy the dip great so are you able to
psychologically do that or are you just
like hey
my position is set i hope the rest of
you suckers by the dip so that uh
you know we keep this upward momentum
yeah so technically i'm over 100 of my
net worth in bitcoin because i took a
small levered position
back when bitcoin was seven thousand
dollars at the bottom of the cycle
uh because i believe that bitcoin you
know in a bull run obviously appreciates
so right
i uh technically over 100 my net worth
is in bitcoin uh also
i do something where i lend out my
bitcoin to earn a yield yeah that yield
is like kind of a day-to-day stacking
mechanism to add more sats to add more
bitcoin
and you're using what like uh kraken
block file would you use them so
crack it doesn't have you're at cracker
now so i put them first but i don't
think they offer this as a service
i appreciate the shout out but no we
don't offer that yet yeah so we've got
like block five let in
and uh genesis trading agendas is
trading you have to have like a minimum
of 20 bitcoin to be a customer
so by the way i bought some secondary
and kraken so i'm i'm with you on on the
christmas train let's
go all the way to the top how the hell
when you're so kraken how many people at
kraken do you think
have more than 15 million dollars how do
you employ people when they're all
[__]
yeah that's what i want to know like how
often they tell you like
you know what dad go [__] yourself i'm
out
next week it's like dan i'm bored you
got a spot for me
yeah you know it's a particular
challenge for crypto i mean crypto it's
the hardest industry to build a business
in think about it this way too like
you've got monsoon seas in the bull run
and you want to capture all of that
revenue potential
but if you start to spend and deploy
capital through hiring and building
offices and whatnot
by the time that the bull runs over like
when do you turn off the spigot like
when you turn off all that cash flow
going out
and then how much do you cut back and i
think that's really really tricky like
how do you
predict these cycles no one knows if we
did we'd all be trillionaires
and so i think like that's the most
difficult part of this is like how do
you build a business with those
fluctuations in demand
and how do you match expenses to meet
that but yeah i mean you know in terms
of
in terms of employee churn it's super
tricky i actually put in my job
descriptions for my growth marketing
team
no crypto experience required i first
find it really
refreshing when folks come in and
challenge language that we use
in our ads home page app store page etc
on how we describe crypto because i'm
i've been in too long it's hard for me
to zoom all the way out and see what it
looks like from a newbie
right and so one i like that perspective
and two to the motivational issue
i think um you know folks who are new to
crypto are much hungrier
uh than ones who haven't been there um
okay so
let's do this private wealth manager so
what would you actually build here would
it be a services company would it be a
software company what would be the
how would you attack this problem yeah
it's a services company and you can't
take bips on aum that's like an old way
to do it you'd have to figure out some
sort of new model that's maybe more
subscription or something like that
the first and foremost problems you're
tackling taxes
taxes are incredibly complicated for
crypto trades especially if you're going
to defy things
yeah one would be taxes two uh so
taxes not only cover trades but also
covers future tax minimization
strategies
for example there's a trust called a
grat a grat is a great way to pass on
your crypto
to your son daughter et cetera a partner
without any taxable events occurring so
there's all sorts of very advanced
structures that
exist for very wealthy folks that most
crypto people have no idea
you know that there was it wasn't
institutional wealth they didn't they
didn't work at goldman
they were in their basement mining
bitcoin or mining ethereum you know like
it's a whole different world right right
and that's we're going to trust
different things
in fact i think yeah what you did where
you built your brand
and you're like oh build a big audience
i think you have a few hundred thousand
followers on twitter for bitcoin
i think that's what you would do if you
come out and you're like hey i'm the
bitcoin tax guy
and i'm gonna talk every day about how
to like deal with the tax problem of
bitcoin and wealth management for
wealthy bitcoiners and i'm gonna
my sales is all gonna happen through
content and then whoever
and then you'll probably get
billionaires coming inbound saying hey
will you manage my stuff
um that's how you would do this i've
known these billionaires personally for
eight years
so i actually dm'd a bunch of them and
asked them if they used multi-family
offices and no i did
right i already know that it's a problem
that they're not currently solving uh
they went
they went to some traditional financial
folks and they talked to me about their
experiences and i was like wow that
sounds terrible
right so for me i'm very happy at kraken
i love the team i'm working with i love
the team i've built
um also they acquired my company so i'm
very incentivized to stick around but i
couldn't be more excited
in terms of a rocket ship in this space
kraken's a great spot to be at and i'm a
growth guy
so it's all about that like hyper growth
and kraken's like a perfect perfect
spot but this is more for fun on the
side of thinking like what
we're all we're all tinker tinker with
stuff and think through stuff and this
is kind of my recent fascination
so sam do you know about the like the
tether
uh question mark have you heard this sam
no
okay so uh i'll i'll ask dan to kind of
explain it so dan i'm gonna ask you
to do two things one is explain what
people are
what some people are afraid of with
tether and why that might be like you
know people
call it oh is this the black swan that's
gonna crash all of crypto
et cetera et cetera and then how you
sleep at night being
100 of your net worth in bitcoin knowing
that this
potential question mark exists with
tether so so explain the potential
problem and then how you think about it
sure so tether is called a stable coin a
stable coin is a representation of a
fiat currency so tether represents
us dollars and it's called usdt
so usdt is created by companies wiring
money in
to a cayman island entity and they wire
it in there and then tethers are minted
and created and those are put on
blockchains uh tether has existed on the
bitcoin blockchain ethereum blockchain
and tron blockchain
amongst others i think as well so what
that tether represents is a one-to-one
backing of a dollar
now the company that issues these uh
which is like tether united
like tether limited plus uh bitfinex
which is an exchange
there were concerns over if they were
truly backed one to one
and there were moments when it wasn't
but they've recently reached a
settlement
with a believe the new york district
attorney i think is who they
i forget exactly who they settled with
this attorney general new york attorney
general i think there's so many
regulators i forget who who settled with
who
but um yeah they essentially settled and
agreed to
do audited to perform audits and come
out with exactly how much they had in
reserve
so the controversy and the worry is that
tethers are
i so there's a couple worries one is
that tethers
um you know first and foremost aren't
backed and that could lead to a kind of
like a classic run on the bank situation
where more people try to redeem tethers
and that
there's none of tet there's not enough
dollars in the bank to be able to redeem
to be able to be redeemed
and that would cause structural problems
at the crypto ecosystem
number two i think is like the idea that
usdt
is being used in smart contracts and
defy and it's completely centralized
because
usdt like usdc these stable coins that
are centrally issued by
companies like tether and circle they
can be reversed
or or frozen or paused and that truly
decentralized and a lot of this a lot of
the defy space
i think a lot of the contracts for
example like maker dao
so so maker dow is like a uh like an
algorithmic stable coin
almost 50 percent of its collateral is
centralized stable coins so
it represents a systemic risk to defy
and centralized finance aka the exchange
base so the fear is basically if the
tether people are not being on the up
and up
so you have to trust people which is
like kind of the anti-crypto way
um if they're ju they could just be
printing tethers
um or be holding not one to one dollar
assets so they could be like a bank
fractionally reserving saying oh for
every dollar we have we have
five tethers um and basically using that
to buy and that's being used by bitcoin
so it's like artificially
it's not that bitcoin has any issue with
it but that's what's driving up
run-ups in price is there's a huge
amount of bitcoin that's bought with
tether
and so that's the question the concern
now how legitimate is the concern
so if we dig into it i wrote about this
uh and the held report
my newsletter if you dig into this there
it isn't as bad as people say
um there's all sorts of moments when
tether wasn't fully collateralized as in
there wasn't enough tether to be
redeemed to dollars
and the industry was fine um also we're
talking about
exchanges don't hold tethers the users
hold tethers
so tether is just like any other crypto
asset so there's been tons of times when
multi-billion dollar crypto assets have
gone to zero
and the structural problems in the space
have been okay we've also suffered much
more egregious moments in the crypto
space like malcox
now gox represented 90 of trading volume
this would be like binance coinbase and
kraken all going down at the same time
you know these are hugely stressful
moments for the um
for the marketplace and so bitcoin has
been through a lot worse
bitcoin inherently doesn't need tether
tethers being used to buy
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies but
for example like um
different other government fiat
currencies are used to buy bitcoin but
that doesn't mean that bitcoin is
dependent on the dollar
it's not dependent on usdt and then i
think you know another concern that i
forgot to bring up earlier
people hypothesize like tether is being
used to pump bitcoin
i think that's completely unfounded it
was based on a university of texas
research report
which i don't even know if you could
call it [__] research but it was like
a research report where they basically
said that
correlation is causation right which is
absurd it's like saying that like you
know uh
umbrellas cause rain because they're
correlated
so it's really ridiculous that's where
the core root of some of the concerns
that like others being used to pump
bitcoin come from
completely unfounded there's no data
that supports that
and also there's moments when tethers
are printed when bitcoin goes down but
of course the people who buy into this
whole theory ignore those moments
right and uh okay so so that's a great
answer
so you um i want to switch to basically
talking about uh other bitcoin or
other other let's say crypto ideas that
you see that
uh the average person is either not
knowing about you know it's an
interesting idea that you're not
that that's not as well known yet or you
see the opportunity for somebody to go
build do you see any other opportunities
besides the private wealth management
space
the private wealth management one for me
is one that's just really sticky
that one's like super interesting other
ones that would be good as well
i just think simplicity is the ultimate
way to go build product it means that
folks find value in your product much
more quickly
you can convey the value prop people
discover the value prop they could
activate it at a higher rate
so i think like simplistic a very very
simple
very very simple mobile experience for
wallets i think is still like
very underappreciated i think the wallet
spaces still has horrid
user experience like for example let's
say when you send a bitcoin transaction
bitcoin transactions have two states
unconfirmed and confirmed
and to a lame a layperson like what does
that even mean
yeah you know and all wallets default to
this language and i would disagree that
they should even default to that
language i mean you should
add a layer in the layer above that and
the gui
of something much more understandable
wallets are kind of fundamental the core
ethos of the system
and there's a lot of things you can do
now where you layer in
trading capabilities built in there etc
so i think that what the space still
doesn't have
great great to use wallets i think like
exodus wallet is really good
but other than them i haven't seen like
an experience around the core experience
of holding your crypto
that was just mind-blowingly amazing do
you have a security team
like a physical security team do we like
guards and [__] no you um
well i'm in texas so obviously i own a
few guns um
so it's a come and take it sort of
attitude at conferences i do have
security who do you hire
um it's it's uh you know provided to me
by
uh through the company how much do they
spend
each year on on these security security
guards you know
i'm not sure but uh but kraken is
constantly focused about security
they're kind of nuts when it comes to
security at crack and it's in terms of
like how you control like where your
laptop is and everything else
they're in exchange right kraken's been
around for 10 years
and has never been hacked so for us like
they're constantly paranoid about that
and the human attack vector
is the weak point in any text system so
they're very conscious about like
different executives and high-profile
individuals like where they are
um you know if they're at events with a
lot of people they got to think about
physical security so it's something that
they think they think about all the time
i have no idea how much that cost though
i would be curious to hear about that
because whenever i see
i mean i i don't have i i'm in a
different friend group as you
maybe i've got a few friends that have
tens of millions of bitcoin
but um i am always curious as to how
like the
the actual security because i would
think that when it comes to hacking i
would think it would be just like
stealing like kidnapping someone
stealing stealing the person as opposed
to
trying to break into the thing totally
yeah and that's actually classically
called the
wrench attack in the bitcoin world is
that someone could come to you and just
crack you over the head with the wrench
right
now at the same time you know sam you've
done very well and st michonne like you
guys have both done very well and we see
you guys know billionaires that walk
around the streets of san francisco
and they're not getting mugged and and
kidnapped
for ransom so in in with bitcoin yeah
bitcoin is easily transferable
but let's say that let's say this person
is not into bitcoin at all
they can easily take their liquid assets
buy bitcoin and then transfer it to the
kidnapper so
whether or not you hold bitcoin if that
makes you more or less susceptible to
getting attacked i don't think it does
well that doesn't necessarily seem fair
like but that said i'm not
uh i'm not entirely educated on it so
i'm not sticking by this quite hardly
or i'm not sticking to this entirely but
like
when i when i have money in a variety of
different places there's
a pretty large amount of checks and
balances that go into transferring it so
i just try to transfer money to a
another bank today and there was like a
hard cut off whereas with a lot of
crypto stuff
you can literally have it in a uh
in like a store like some type of store
like physical
i could fat finger the number i'm
putting in and i could transfer
you know instead of five i could
transfer five thousand you know yeah
and i also and there's no getting it
back and like credit cards do a pretty
good job of doing
fraud protection um um
usually is it what's it called what's
the the 250 000 of checking
accounts are uh our insurer fda
yeah it's also a big problem of like
death right so uh
so i think there's a startup opportunity
here too which is what happens to your
bitcoin when you die
and um and and how do you how do you
manage that so
on one hand you can leave instructions
to your spouse or whatever which is like
hey
to get all to get access to all of our
private keys here's what you do but now
you have instructions to get all your
private keys that's
you know somewhere uh you have to
protect that
and so you have to have multiple layers
you're starting to go down the rabbit
hole you're starting to yeah yeah
you get you kind of get in the circular
logic loop of like well i can't trust
anyone else with my money
so i need to manage my private key and
it's like well if i want to pass it on i
have to trust with them
yeah exactly and then actually and then
you also have the like i
do the problem of like actually like
property uh you know property transfer
when you die is like it goes through
either probate or you have a will and
i just think that there's probably a lot
there that if you if you look at this
group of crypto wealthy as just a new
customer that exists
and they're gonna it's i have this
framework this two by two which is like
you know um is it an old problem or a
new problem
and then is there an old solution or new
solution right and so this is a case
where it's it's a bunch of old problems
but we need a new solution because it's
a new type of customer
it goes back to the private wealth
management exactly there's actually a
way to solve this too it's called
multi-signature
which means that your bitcoin isn't
controlled by one key that opens up the
vault
there's three keys and you need two out
of three keys to open up the vault
and there's all sorts of like there's
three out of five key structures so
those would be how you do this through
time as you give like your your your cpa
one your wife wife or husband one day
yeah and then you give the other two to
whomever else or you keep three on your
own
so there's a lot of elegant ways to do
that multisig i think is the only way
that's like
but the thing is now you have to educate
your there's no cpa in the world that
knows
private key management well right that's
where this entity would for example be
one of the key holders
they would know very good private key
management practices and only sign as
for under certain conditions which would
also help against the
kidnapping vector and where they would
have like a velocity limit
you've dm me before about stuff that's
in the
creator kind of like audience space um i
don't know where you want to go with
that i'll kind of leave it open but
uh you seem to have like a theory or a
framework of like where the puck is
going when it comes to the creator thing
or like
i don't know you've successfully built
your personal brand and
you know like i don't know how many
years ago nobody knew who the [__] dan
hell is and
today you're known by a bunch of you
know crypto nerds so
like what is the what is you you give me
your thought process around
either one of those two like generally
where it's going are for you
specifically how you think about it
yeah so i'm like i'm a growth product
growth marketing guy so when i find like
a vein of gold where i find like
engagement or i find user acquisition it
just fascinates me right so
the creator economy is about you know
for the i think or most folks on the
show i'd say up to speed with creator
economy stuff
okay cool so um you know i built an
audience in the crypto space in the
bitcoin space
my main message is just bitcoin though
so i'm straight to the bitcoin ethos
i've been in a long time so and my last
name is a pun on the favorite meme
hoddle right so my last name actually is
real though
my last name truly is hell it's actually
a german last name um
which and so uh with that i decided to
lean into that
and i just started to write i wrote long
form articles i started to tweet
and those got traction and i found
over time that there's a certain way
that these gain traction
it's it's not it's not by random
circumstance there are ways to
understand the engagement algorithm and
use that to propagate your message
for me i really love bitcoin what's an
example well it's an example of
something you saw that was working sure
well you can do twitter advanced search
and search for
the most popular tweets from any account
filter though but
filter those by the most popular and
then actually take a format of what
they've tweeted and just take an
iteration of that
right you already know it's probably
going to work and you just take a small
tweak and that's that almost always
works yep
you could also do a quote tweet where
like let's say
let's say like a novel tweet you can
just copy paste neval's
quote with quotes and tag neval and
you'll get almost as much engagement
of all those yeah even if you're a
really tiny account so
little things like that there's a whole
bunch of those that are discovered um
because yeah again i'm a growth
marketing guy so i'm digging in and i'm
like oh man this this engagement tactic
really worked
i've done some things like if you see
auto playing videos you can build those
in the media center
in twitter which you have to have an ads
account to do those but they're not an
ad
it's organic so little little tips and
tricks like that
um consistency i think is the number one
thing that people forget i have not
missed tweeting a day in three years
if you do you lose your spot in the
relevancy engine with twitter
so twitter every day uh there's there's
like 90
of consumers and 10 of us creators well
the creators create content for the
board consumers the consumer session and
the product
and twitter needs to figure out how to
hook them immediately
and so twitter goes to all their
previous engaged content and they go
well
who do they engage with every day and if
they've built up a habit of engaging
with myself
then they're like well let's give them a
damn hell tweet but if i don't tweet
that day
then there may be like oh let's give
them a chris tweet or someone else's
tweet
because they need to go hook them
immediately and then if that engagement
loop gets built with them over time
then also slowly start to lose relevancy
with them
so consistency is absolutely the most
important thing on twitter and most
of these channels i think that was like
the really big breakthroughs for me it's
not
quality it's quantity it's about always
having content there for them to consume
and building that habit
and then you over time you focus on
quality where i think i've gotten a
little bit more high quality over time
especially like i've stood up a youtube
channel i've got 25 000 subs
in six months and i just shoot one
continuous shot
i don't i don't even edit it i just do
one continuous shot even if i like
sneeze or something i just kind of like
keep going
because i don't have enough time to
spend in post-production and doing cuts
you guys have great video content i just
don't have time to go do that how
they're doing
it's all about like does my audience
does my audience like will they engage
with the content well
it's an mvp right it's an mvp if people
like it
then you go spend time you you pay for
an editor or something to go help out
um but yeah it's been a it's been an
incredible journey going down this
rabbit hole and then
you know monetization-wise too just
seeing all the different ways that folks
you know tipping on
on twitch you've got like tipping on
twitter now you've got subscription
products you've got swag
three years from now audience keeps
growing and the money the monetization
things get
more baked out for you how much do you
think an individual creator in your
niche like how much do you think you can
make three years from now just on the
personal brand side of things forget the
job and
investigating and other stuff have you
guys talked to pomp yet
yeah we've heard a couple times yeah and
we both know him well i don't
we i mean i mean ask him that but that
question yeah but if i if i have we
i can but we can guess
okay so out not let's not include
investment revenue which i think
investment revenue
in the next uh so we're talking about
like paid newsletter
sponsorships uh recurring revenue i
think we should throw in there because
that's kind of like part of the personal
brand stuff courses now
courses yeah but let's just say though
his his investment revenue if you told
me that it makes
him personally 30 million dollars spread
evenly over the next 10 years i wouldn't
be surprised
is that crazy john did you hear are you
talking about 30 total
sorry 30 total spread out evenly over 10
years yeah i don't know how big this
fund is so i'm just going to take that
out for a second i think
yeah just the personal brand which is
two and a half to an hour
i would say three and a half what would
you have guessed dan two to four million
is my best guess as of how much revenue
he's making and that's based on like my
best knowledge
right maybe five people on staff so
maybe half a million
in costs yeah very very little overhead
so very high margins
right um these are all value of creative
too like if someone gets gets a job
through pomp
they might be really inclined to sign up
to his newsletter right these are like
mutually exclusive
sales right um but by far i think like
so he
he's got the so pomp is the biggest pomp
is so this is our upper bound limit and
that's why i chose pomp right
is the biggest what about uh in the
bitcoin in the crypto space you're
talking about
what about uh my guy uh ralph powell or
is that his name brow power
yeah ralph powell he's more of like uh
macro
finally i mean i guess we could call him
krypto now because he's like there are
these
even though like let's say like a guy
who's kind of a troll even though i love
him like a james dalton
like a james altucher i bet you makes 30
million dollars a year in crypto
newsletters
dude i don't i don't think james i'll
teach you that guys from like 2017 era
he's a friend of mine dude he sold his
new new his crypto newsletter for 60
million dollars
wow wow yes holy [__] i didn't even know
that you know motley fool
yeah motley fool does close to 100
million a month in revenue
um so i i think that pomp is the
popular poppy one but i think they're i
bet you i
guarantee you there's guys who have
newsletters that they charge 20 000 a
year
well you guys have uh you guys did the
breakdown of agora right
that like crazy newsletter thing they
bought james
yeah oh okay yeah i mean i got the i got
the
you know after you guys did the
breakdown of it i actually talked to
someone who worked there
yeah and got the breakdown so like that
back-end newsletter the one that's a
really high markup
like the thousand dollars a month that's
where they make all the money yeah
it's like you got your twenty thirty
dollar a month up front one and you get
the thousand dollar
back and one i couldn't personally do it
i just feel kind of weird doing it
personally were we wrong
by the way were we wrong on our guesses
for agora
in terms of like uh the revenue i didn't
do any revenue back at the envelope
revenue stuff i just want to know
tactically
like how do they think about it i'm with
you dan there is something to that like
oh this like weird slippery slope where
you end up with these like
you know this small one percent of these
like whales who you've just
milked their whole life savings because
they think they're getting this thing no
no thanks
i'd rather build longer term value to
like deliver something i think is truly
worth that amount of money
that's where i've experimented with
courses so i've got my newsletter i've
got my newsletter i've got ads
which one is the best the best
combination of like effort
fun and money like if you combine those
right you want a low effort high five
high money
like what is the best one so far you've
experimented as
a creator of these tools in your tool
belt probably youtube
because i it's kind of fun showing a
product that you really so i only
represent products that i personally use
right it's an ethical standard that i
have for myself so which means that i
have eliminated a lot of the potential
advertisers that would pay me a lot more
right for me it's the only way that i
feel like it'd be appropriate for me to
you know represent this product um
then the youtube is fun because i get to
like have like a little skit with it
where i like i bring it up i talk about
it
i represent it the newsletter it's a lot
of work
um that i mean writing an article a week
doesn't sound like
a lot
it's a ton of work and you take pride in
it but when it's paid there's a bar of
these people paid for this information
so the information that better be
different and unique and awesome
everybody
i know i'm a i'm a you know classic
growth guy so i have a survey at the end
of each one to get like a raw mps score
i get feedback on what the next article
they want written that way i write the
best most relevant content
which means that they're satisfied but
it's tough you know like
it it's really hard to where i don't
know how pomp does it daily
i think he's got a guy i i would bet
that he's got about two young guys
he says he doesn't he says he sits down
he writes it in one take
um well i i went out to me and my wife
and him and his wife all went out to
lunch one day and just hung out
and uh paulina his wife was teasing him
like
like she was like it takes me forever to
wipe write my weekly thing
he just sits down and he does it in 15
minutes and he's done
i mean i've i've had some that have like
cruised through like a straight like
stream of consciousness but it's tough
some of them i do a lot of research for
like i wrote one on bitcoin defy
and that was a ton of like actually i
tried to try out a couple different apps
it was a lot of work so fun and roi
would be youtube channel
where like i do these pre-world mid-roll
ads they're kind of fun to do
i can visually show off the product in a
more fun compelling way
like the products i'm representing uh
versus like the newsletter which i have
to sit down really think through hard
and it's something that
you know i want to make sure i represent
really really well by the way your
growth guy
um i've said that this bitcoin laser
eyes thing is one of the most genius
kind of like decentralized marketing
tactics i've ever seen um
what is the origin story is there an
organization
i'm saying do you know he knows more
people than i do where did this come
from and
who are the geniuses that came up with
this yeah so i wrote about bitcoin's
decentralized marketing team before
where like bitcoin has no central
marketing org there's no propaganda arm
of bitcoin it's like me
and pomp and everyone else who talks
about bitcoin i don't know who
originated it it's like the origin of
memes i mean
sometimes you can find where a meme came
from but sometimes it just kind of like
it came from nowhere
i'm not sure who the first person was
and no one i know has claimed it
which is insane because somebody should
and uh and you could you could be the
first
person who did this right that's not
like uh that's not like a wild thing
and but it's genius it is like bitcoin
in so many ways is a religion
and um and this is just yet another like
you know religious mark basically you
know this is the yamaka this is
this is the thing you wear that that
says hey i'm a part of this religion
and um you know putting it in the
profile picture having it be slightly
mysterious so people don't know what
it's for and then they ask
and then making it memeable where we can
all do it i think is it was
just brilliant brilliant brilliant
really yeah
this basis i mean memes are such an
incredible part of how
stuff is communicated nowadays right
like i mean we saw like elections
that can people can be elected based on
memes like
memes aren't just these funny things on
like 4chan or reddit anymore like memes
are
the memes are like the main trend like
my mom uses memes
now she does it on my facebook but you
know it's
it's crazy like it's narrative
compression at its finest it's taking a
whole narrative
and compressing it into one image and i
think that's why it's so powerful as a
transmission
it's the most shareable viral thing you
can do right on the internet and so it's
like
what you know memes are the packaging
for ideas
if you want to most efficiently package
an idea a meme is the best way so i've
joked about
uh we saw this thing called i think was
called like
meme university or lol university or
something like that
and basically they took the website of
lambda school and they just remade it
for a school that would teach you how to
do memes
it was a joke website that was not like
a real course behind it
but i was like you know if there really
should be a course that somebody should
take this is it
um people but people if you could learn
this it's
learning you know the native tongue of
the internet um and and
you know it's pretty important to be
fluent in internet nowadays and so i
think
i think that's one where i'm like if
somebody really should create this
i have this slack channel that me and
ben do where we basically put out a
challenge where we said
every day for 50 days we're gonna make a
new meme um
because you know it's easy to spread
these but the act of actually making one
is hard it's telling
it you know telling a story telling a
joke in the most efficient form
and it's been so challenging to just do
this every day for 50 days
well what's kind of fun is um my buddies
over at etoro brad mitchelson
really really smart marketing guy him
and i buddies and what they did is they
started to create gifs
on so on giphy and giphy like that
that's a good that gets pulled into like
facebook messenger
search engine twitter gifs so i started
to make i saw their strategy for etoro
and i made that for myself
so i took like the most popular bitcoin
memes and then wrapped it in my own
black and white design
to where you could search like dan held
and you'd see a bunch of black and white
gifs
and have my my logo watermarked on there
so like
you can kind of create meme factories is
what i learned from that like you can
create like a meme factory to use that
to propagate content
and giphy was a really great way of
doing it because it's plugged into so
many different
platforms versus like if you you know
each one individually like trying to
create like an emoji
with each social platform would be tough
but like giphy gets pulled into all of
them
yeah that's smart i like that all right
we're about at the top of the hour
uh do we want to go over one more idea
or what sean um
i don't know if you have if you have one
that's burning you can do it otherwise i
think we should
uh wrap it up cool well yeah i mean just
my i think
like closing thought on like the creator
economy stuff um i've been in bitcoin
for nine years
and that has been a huge fascination for
me i would say the creator economy
is not an equal fascination but quickly
becoming something very interesting
um i think about it as like the
monetization of all and
human information right like creators
are just taking whatever
knowledge they have locally putting that
on the internet distributing it and then
monetizing that
and what is the value of all of that
combined i mean it's
tens of trillions 100 trillion i don't
know what it's worth but like
for me i just kind of see this huge i
mean there's so many niche things that
someone could write about
like there's a million things and it's
very low
very low effort to find your mvp versus
before you had to go buy a warehouse and
start producing things
you just produce content and if that
content resonates and people click
and want to figure out what products
you'd recommend for them then you can go
build your own products so i see kind of
like a whole
the economy kind of reorienting around
content marketing
and that being the top of funnel in in
like idea generation for all future
products
great well what do you think sean
yeah let's wrap it up i like that one
that that's uh
i like the way you explained that
because i think it it aligns with
something i believe which is when when
there's never been more information
it's all about who actually has
attention and the person who's gonna
have attention is whoever
is putting out great content
consistently so great content once we'll
get your attention once and then great
content consistently will build
trust which just says look it's too
noisy i'm just gonna go to my sources i
like
and um and then those people then hold
the keys
and you know up till now that's been
captured by the platform so
that's been true but youtube still
captured way more value and twitch
captured way more value and twitter
captured way more value than the people
on it
and that seems to be flipping uh where
where
either new platforms are going to come
out where the creators own it or
the the value is going to accrue off
platform in a bigger way than it did
originally when it was like i think the
value accrued like 99
1. um 99 to the platform 1 to the
creators
and i think that's that's gonna flip uh
closer to 50 50 over time
i think twitter has recognized this
right with the super follows where you
can have like subscription followers
where people subscribe to like a premium
set of tweets you have
i mean twitter i think sees this coming
they see the exodus of folks building an
audience on twitter
and then the exodus of all that
monetization going to sub stack
you're trying to bring that back in yeah
i think that's sort of just trading one
master for another though in a way where
it's like as long as
twitter will put super follows there and
then they'll take the cut they want and
then as long as they're
they're the button to pay for stuff they
can they'll just inch that cut
from 10 to 15 to 20 to 50 over time
and um and so i think you know the real
answer here is
is how do you build this independently
and i think basically
that that's the part of crypto i'm most
excited about is people who are building
uh you know a social network that is
open source um that if it can get
adoption
and this is why i was interested in big
cloud is if it can get adoption
then uh that ratio will flip the
the all the value will accrue to the
creators and not to the core platform or
protocol underneath
um so so that's what i'm excited about
is like that's the real disruption there
well we appreciate you coming on dan um
it's uh i've been following you on
twitter now for
a couple weeks since uh uh sean's been
talking about you and he's been saying
that you were the guy to speak to
and and we appreciate it yeah so go go
give him a follow he's at
dan held on twitter and uh yeah all
right we'll see you we'll see you later
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to
never looking back